Hypocrisy no longer knows any bounds in the
American right wing.
If I say to you, lock her up, what do you
think of if you were paying attention during
the 2016 election?
When I say lock her up, your mind should immediately
go to all of those calls to lock up Hillary.
During the Republican National Convention,
everyone from Donald Trump's now indicted
national security advisor, Michael Flynn,
who was a, they're a of egging on crowds that
Trump's a, uh, rallies or the RNC wherever,
uh, to lock her up, lock her up to crowd's
chanting it at Trump's rallies.
While Trump looks around smiling and pleased
to Trump's tweets, to Trump's debate statement,
that if he were in charge of the justice system,
that Hillary would be in jail.
They've been calling for Hillary to be locked
up despite not having been charged with any
crime despite the obvious reality that Hillary
Clinton is not going to be charged with any
crime.
And recent, uh, uh, recently speaker of the
house, Nancy Pelosi said, rather than impeached
Trump, she'd like to see them in prison.
Now we can argue about whether Nancy Pelosi's
position on impeachment makes sense.
We can have a debate about all of that, but
there is no question that this is not a unique
thing.
On one side of the aisle, on the one hand,
Nancy Pelosi says she'd like to see Trump
in prison for the list of crimes that Robert
Mueller said.
There is substantial evidence for, and on
the other hand lock her up has been uh, you
know, a, a, a, a stall warts, a fixture of
the American right for three years at this
point.
But Fox News propagandists Sean Hannity is
outraged at Nancy Pelosi saying that calls
to lock up political opponents are quote,
despicable does hypocrisy.
No longer matter.
Do double standards no longer make any difference?
And the answer is they don't to the right,
we've been pointing that out for a long time.
Check out what Sean Hannity had to say despite
these obvious flaws is by as this deception
molars report the irrefutable fact that there
was no collusion.
Of course the rage Trump democratic party,
they're just hell bent on one thing.
One thing only.
And that's impeaching the president.
They don't have a reason, they don't stay
to reason.
But of course they get the assistance of the
psychotic media mobs, conspiracy theorists,
liars.
And tonight this is no longer a democratic
party like of Scoop Jackson, even Joe Lieberman.
Instead, it is now the party of anti Trump
rage in psychosis.
And for some reason, even impeaching Trump
apparently is not enough that speaker Pelosi
now apparently telling senior Democrats, you'd
like to see Trump behind bars, uh, based on
no actual crime.
She wants a political opponent locked up in
prison.
Um, that happens in banana republics beyond
despicable behavior.
And by the way, they would literally turn
in many ways the USA into a country.
We no longer recognize way.
Do it.
Whoa.
Hold on.
Then a second.
You're saying that telling political opponents
not charged of any crime, that you want them
locked up or you plan to lock them up or you
would lock them up if you were in charge?
Are you're saying Sean, that that's unbecoming
of the United States and it's like what happens
in so called the banana republics?
I got it.
Well, remember when Donald Trump said this
to Hillary Clinton during the debate in 2016?
You know, it is, uh, it's just awfully good
that someone with the temperament of Donald
Trump is not in charge of the law in our country.
Yeah, because you'd be in jail secretary.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Jeff sessions previously chanted, lock her
up.
There's a very long list, but the problem
is Nancy Pelosi wanting to see Trump in jail
for crimes that the Mueller report says there
is substantial evidence of irony is dead.
Satire no longer exists or never existed on
the right.
Intellectual consistency is completely irrelevant.
I've talked about how Donald Trump has weaponized
ignorance in this country.
He's also a weaponized hypocrisy for all of
my focus on Trump.
I keep trying to remind you that Trump is
a symptom, not the disease.
This is a really good example.
The disease is the anti intellectual ism that
has spread throughout the country and American
conservatism and has allowed someone like
Trump to come in Trump appealing to the basest
instincts of the American right wouldn't be
possible if they were not.
Uh, appealable to I guess is what I'm trying
to say on that basis.
Weaponizing their ignorance about everything
from trade to immigration is Donald Trump
successfully did during his presidential campaign.
That is not something that Trump created.
Trump took advantage of it.
And in the same way, there is this immunity
to their own hypocrisy that Donald Trump is
able to weaponize, that the American right
is able to weaponize that propaganda.
Outlets like Fox News certainly know how to
weaponize and this problem proceeds Donald
Trump.
This problem is going to continue after Donald
There is no doubt whatsoever.
And this is just one example of that.
It's an embarrassing one.
But on the Fox News Echo Chamber, it does
really well and it really fires up the base.